[Applause]
and finally new rule don't wish ill
health on president trump but just
because he got sick don't forget that
he's still out there trying to steal an
election
three years ago in this space i talked
about that most famous word from the
declaration of independence
self-evident we hold these truths to be
self-evident well we were wrong
it took almost 250 years but we found a
guy for which nothing
is self-evident like
like leaving office when there's an
election and you lose
not self-evident don't put your
son-in-law in charge of the government
not self-evident don't keep operating a
for-profit business empire while you're
in office
you know little things we didn't think
we had to write down
release your taxes get your cabinet
confirmed
don't use the white house for a partisan
convention don't accept foreign help in
an election
care for all the states not just the
ones that voted for you
little things
take sides only with the countries named
america
nothing is self-evident to this man sure
the law says you can vote by mail but it
doesn't say anything about
[ __ ] with the place that handles the
mail
this
this guy finds loopholes like bird [ __ ]
finds my windshield
if there's one thing we've learned from
this presidency it's that you have to
get everything in writing
because if you don't he will do a gus
what's a gus gus is that disney movie
from the 70s i keep talking about that
no one remembers
so let me describe it once again gus is
a mule
that is signed by a football team to
kick field goals with his powerful mule
leg and when the other teams object the
gus
team just says two bad suckers the rule
book doesn't specifically say
the players have to be human
everyone just assumed that so [ __ ] you
we're going to do it
that's trump's philosophy on everything
if you
if you don't specifically write down
that i can't do something i will
now we've all seen a gus in real life
but it's usually just a guy at the
costco sample table who notices there's
no one per customer sign and says great
dinner
but it's different when the president is
a gus and i'm here to warn you tonight
that our field goal
kicking leader is now planning his
ultimate gust which is screwing
with the electoral college you see we
don't have direct
presidential elections in america we
have a middleman
the electors they're the ones who
actually convene on december 14th and
cast
ballots to determine who is president
now in the past no one ever questioned
if you win the state
you get the electors because we're a
democracy
sort of but it turns out
that's not a law it's not in the
constitution and it's not written down
uh-oh gus alert
the trump campaign's legal advisor told
the atlantic on the record
that if there is any hint of voting
irregularities republican state
legislatures
might say and i quote we don't think the
results of our own state are accurate
so here's our slate of electors that we
think properly reflect the results of
our state
in other words [ __ ] the vote we're
telling our electors to vote for the
other guy
so it's a completely plausible scenario
that biden wins the popular vote in
florida say
but then trump starts ranting about how
people are saying
an alligator ate a box of ballots in
tallahassee
and that's all the cover needed for the
republican-controlled state house and
republican governor to say
until we get to the bottom of this we're
not sending our electors to vote for
biden
now do you see why i feel like i've just
been tied up by a german dominatrix who
doesn't understand my safe word
and republicans control both
legislative chambers in the six most
key battleground states at very least
they can make things so chaotic that
neither candidate gets
270 electoral votes and then the
election goes to the house
where each state gets one vote
so 26 votes wins
how many state delegations do
republicans control
26 we never catch a break
but don't get discouraged vote vote
early
and vote often but get ready
for trump to gus the election
you